[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه من مستقبل الطاقه
وهذه ملفاتنا
الكهرباء المتنقله هل تشكل حلا لزلزال
تركيا والفساد في لبنان
[موسيقى]
وفي الامارات ائتلاف بين شركات كبرى
لاعاده تصميم صناعه التغليف بما يتناسب مع
حاجات عاده التدوير
[موسيقى]
الكهرباء كانت في قلب ازمه الطاقه التي
عاشتها اوروبا منذ اندلاع الحرب
الاوكرانيه وهي عصب قطاع الطاقه الذي يدخل
في كل تفاصيل الحياه من التدفئه الى
الاناره الى النقل واخيرا السيارات
الكهربائيه ولذلك لن تتفاجئوا اذا علمتم
ان انتاج الكهرباء في اوروبا سجل انخفاضا
من النادر ان يحدث وبنسبه
3.5% العمل الماضي بحسب تقرير لوكاله
الطاقه الدوليه والاسباب معروفه اولها
الاجراءات المشدده لترشيد استهلاك الطاقه
في المنازل والحياه العامه لمواجهه انقطاع
امدادات الغاز الروسيه بشكل خاص وثانيها
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه الذي ادى الى تدمير
الطلب او ديمان ديستركشن لاسيما في القطاع
الصناعي
ونتيجه لذلك تباطا نمو طلب العالمي على
الكهرباء الى اثنين في المئه في 2022
مقارنه بمعدل 2.4% في السنوات ما بين 2015
و 2019 لكن في مناطق اخرى من العالم وصل
انتاج الكهرباء النمو لا سيما في الولايات
المتحده والهند اما في الصين فكان النمو
ضعيفا بسبب قيود كوفيد المفارقه الكبرى ان
قطاع الكهرباء هو اكبر مسبب لانبعاثات
ثاني اكسيد الكربونه عالميا لكنه في الوقت
ذاته القطاع الذي يقود تحول الطاقه وكلنا
نعرف شعار للاكتيفاي افري من السيارات الى
العديد من المجالات الاخرى
وبالتالي لا معنى للتحول للسيارات
الكهربائيه اذا كانت الكهرباء المستخدمه
لشحنها تاتي من مصادر تقليديه وفي حين ان
العالم كان متجها الى زياده حصه الطاقات
المتجدده اتت الازمه الاوكرانيه لتعيد
اوروبا الى الاعتماد على الفحم والوقود
الاكثر تلويثا او الطاقه النوويه في انتاج
الكهرباء لكن وكاله الطاقه الدوليه تتوقع
ان تسيطر الطاقات المتجدده والنوويه على
90% من الطلب الاضافي على الكهرباء في
السنوات الثلاث المقبله فيما سيظل توليد
الكهرباء من الغاز والفحم مستقرا
[موسيقى]
محطات وتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه المتنقله
ذات التوربينات الغازيه منتج تقني انتشر
بشكل كبير في السنوات الماضيه بعد ان اثبت
فعاليته في حالات الازمات كما في زلزال
تركيا وسوريا او كحل مرحله لدعم الشبكات
الرئيسيه في حال العجز عن تلبيه الطلب كما
في حاله لبنان حيث لا تزيد التغذيه
بالتيار الكهربائي على ثلاث ساعات يوميا
قبلت مدحت المرعبي المدير الاقليمي لوحدات
الطاقه المتنقله في جنرال اليكتريك للطاقه
وسالته عن طبيعه عمل التربينات المتنقله
والحالات التي تستخدم فيها
الغازي المستخدمه في الحطات الكهربائيه
القابله للتنقل هي محطات تستخدم
التكنولوجيا القائمه اليوم في قطاع
الطيران فهي نفس التورمينات المستخدم على
مزاج جدا مهمه يمكن اهمها هيونه فهي قادره
على انتاج طاقه كهربائيه خلال ما يقل عن
خمس دقائق وهي اليوم متاحه لاستخدامات
عديده في المنطقه وفي العالم يمكن اهمها
هي الامن الطاقوي واليوم عم نشهد في
العالم كله بحث لتامين الطاقه السريعه
والطاقه المستدامه بالاضافه الى ذلك هذه
التوربينات اليوم ممكن استخدامها لتلبيه
ودعم التنميه الاقتصاديه والصناعيه
والتنميه السكانيه في مناطق عديه منها
منطقه الخليج العربي ممكن على راسها
المملكه العربيه
من التطورات انا اللي عم تشهد تنامي في
الطلب على هذه هو دخول الطاقه المتجدده
على الشبكات التقليديه والحاجه الى دعام
اذا هذه التقنيه قد تكون احد الحلول التي
تستخدم وقت الازمات او لدعم شبكات حين
ينخفض الجهد الكهربائي فكم تبلغ الطاقه
الانتاجيه لها وهل توفر حلا مرحليا لدول
فيها ازمات كهرباء مثل العراق ولبنان مثلا
الى 100
مستخدمه الغاز الطبيعي او الديزل كما انه
اليوم اذا بننظر الى منطقه في اوروبا ل
استخداما في نطاقات واسعه منها امن الطاقه
حيث تنجم تنتج تنتج الحكومات والدول الى
تنميه مصادر طاقتها
لطريقه تكافل هذه
الطرق المنتجه لل الكهربائيه لتامين طاقه
مستديم بالاضافه الى ذلك نرى ان هذه
التربونات يتم استخدام
الالتزامات البيئيه التي قامت بها
الحكومات عالميا والحكومات المحليه ايضا
حيث نرى اتجاه الى
التزام انتاج سخنون في المدى المتوسط وهذا
ما يلزم الحكومات والشركات انتاج الطاقه
الكهربائيه على البحث على حلول
لطاقه
موثوقه اكثر لما نرى اليوم على شبكات من
نوع من عدم الاستقرار ناتج عن استخدام
الطاقات كم تبلغ الكلفه الانتاجيه لكل
كيلو وات ساعه وكيف تقارن بتكلفه الانتاج
من مصادر اخرى للطاقه
من المحطات المتناقيه مشابهه جدا للمحطات
الغازيه الاخرى وممكن ان تكون هذه التكلفه
اعلى بقليل من التكلفه الطاقه المتجدده
ولكن اليوم جيدا
امن الطاقه هي ماضله ثلاثيه الابعاد ولا
يمكن التغاضي عن اي بعد من هذه الابعاد
اولا يجب تامين طاقه موثوقه ثانيا يجب ان
تكون هذه الطاقه مستدامه وبسعر معقول فلا
يمكن الاستغناء عن اي نوع من هذه الانواع
الطاقه الموجوده الان في السوق وعند دراسه
الجدول الاقتصاديه للمحطات المتنقله نجد
اننا تؤمن وفره ناتجه عن سرعه تامين هذه
الطاقه الكهربائيه كما انها لا تحتاج الى
هنا تحتيه كما هي الحال في المحطات الاخرى
كما انها تؤمن
السكاني والنمو الاقتصادي للمناطق النائيه
وهنا يجر الاشاره الى المشاريع العملاقه
التي تقوم بها وزاره الاسكان في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه حيث نحن الان في اطار
دراسه جدوى لتامين هذه المحطات بهذه
المشاريع الكبرى بحيث يتم التامين
الكهرباء لها قبل وصول الشبكات الى تلك
المشاريع لنتكلم قليلا عن حجم الوفر
الناتج عن هذه المحطات سواء بعمليات
التشغيل او الانبعاثات
تسمحي لي ان القي الضوء قليلا على موضوع
حرق الغاز المصاحب لعمليه انتاج النفر
واليوم يتم حرق كميه كبيره من الغاز
المصاحب في حقول النصر بدلا من استخدام
هذا الغاز لانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه فهذا
الغاز اليوم يحرق يبهدر ويلوث البيئه بعض
الارقام
للساده المشاهدين يبلغ كميه الغاز المصاحب
المحروقه عالميا
144 مليار متر مكعب في المنطقه عندنا في
المنطقه العربيه يتم حرق ما يزيد عن 26
مليار متر مكعب في العراق وليبيا صقر هذه
بكميات هائله من الغاز المصاحب يمكن
استغلالها بشكل سريع ومدروس لانتاج الطاقه
الكهربائيه
المحتاجه جدا اليوم للمناطق
وللسكان في هذا البلدين هل يمكن ان تعمل
هذه التقنيات على مصادر وقود اخرى غير
الغاز وبالتالي كيف تتغير التكلفه
بكل تاكيد بما ان هذه
التوربينات هي التوربينات طائرات فهي
اليوم
بتكنولوجيا
لحرق الهيدروجين
ايضا الديسير العضوي
بشكل مباشر
للحكومه المصريه الحقيقه نجاح في اطار 7
بتهيئه الام 16
لاستخدام من ضمن فعاليه
وقد قامت الكوادر المصريه بشكل ناجح
باعاده تاهيل الاصول الموجوده لها الحكومه
المصريه لانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه يتلائم
مع تقدم قطاع الطاقه
لتامين الاهداف البيئيه الملتزم بها في
موضوع المستخدم للوصول الى
السفره في اقرب وقت
نتوقف مع فاصل قصير نتابع بعده مستقبل
الطاقه ونفتح ملف اعاده التدوير في صناعه
التغليف
[موسيقى]
في الامارات انطلق ائتلاف صناعي بهدف بهدف
التوسع في اعاده التدوير بصناعه التغليف
او الباكجينغ وخلال من خلال جمعيه التغليف
المستدامه وهي شراكه بين القطاعين العام
والخاص تشمل مختلف مراحل سلسله قيمه
التغليف هذا الائتلاف الذي يضم عددا من
الشركات الصناعيه الكبيره يهدف الى دمج
مبادئ الاقتصاد الدائري والاخضر ضمن سلسله
قيمه التغليف بما يسهم في تحويل النظام
القائم حاليا على شراء المنتجات
واستخدامها والتخلص منها الى نظام يعتبر
او
يعتبر نفايات التغليف موردا قيما يمكن
اعاده استخدامه هذا وكانت الامارات قد
اطلقت سياسه الاقتصاد الدائري
2021-2030 للح من الانبعاثات الكربونيه
والتقليل من التلوث بما يسهم في تسريع
الوصول الى الحياه المناخيه بحلول 2050
هذا وكنت قد اجريته لقاء مع رئيسه مجلس
اداره جمعيه التغليف المستدامه التي اكدت
على ضروره تطبيق الاقتصاد الدائري في
النفايات بدول الخليج حيث معدل انتاج
الفرد الواحد من المخلفات اليوميه اعلى
بنحو 68% من المعدلات العالميه
يجب البدء على نطاق المستهلك
بالنسبه للاستثمارات المطلوبه ما هو حجم
هذه الاستثمارات برايك لتحقيق الاهداف
المذكوره
يونير
اليوم
كيف تعملون لضمان وجود البنيه التحتيه
وتشريعات المناسبه لدعم اهدافكم بما في
ذلك اي دعم مطلوب او مسانده من قبل
الحكومه الاماراتيه
طبعا
كيف يمكن الانضمام الى الجمعيه هل هناك
مساهمات ماليه مطلوبه من قبل الاعضاء وهل
هناك اي حوافز تشجعهم على الانضمام
وكيف لمستم الجهوزيه من قبل المستهلكين
باستخدام منتجات مغلفه
بمواد معاد تدبيرها
[موسيقى]
بهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه من مستقبل
الطاقه للمزيد تابعونا على تحت وزن هاشتاق
مستقبل اندر سكور الطاقه يمكنكم ايضا
الاستماع الى حلقاتنا على العربيه بودكاست
اما لمشاهده حلقات البرنامج
[موسيقى]
العربيه
سلاش دوت ناتج بروجرام الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]